hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the uh Julius
bear Generations cup it is the seventh
of nine events of uh the 1.6 million
dollars meltwater Champions chest tour
and it's Arjun arigasi versus Magnus
Carlsen so Magnus is back and for those
of you who are wondering and I know
everyone will be asking this in the
comments when is Magnus uh playing Hans
uh Magnus is playing Hans in round six
of the preliminaries and then uh we'll
see we'll take it from there uh if the
if the game happens uh so let's dive
straight into it it's a very cool quick
game uh so uh you know uh don't blink uh
Arjun has the white pieces and he opens
with Ponte E4 and Magnus already with a
nice surprise spawn to G6 the modern
defense the robot defense he has played
it before and of course uh when you're
facing Magnus you have to be ready for
it we have D6 uh D4 D6 Knight to C3 and
now Bishop to G7 uh we have Bishop to E3
and now Pawn into A6 you can see very
very modern stuff Happening Here Queen
to D2 at some point you might be
interested in trading of the dark Square
Bishops and now Pawn to B5 Magnus really
playing with those pawns uh Pawn to F3
and now Knight to D7 uh having a C5 and
D5 ready to be fired up we have H4 and
now Knight G2 F6 we have Castle's Queen
side and now Pawn to H5 uh not allowing
any quick G4 or a H5 G5 attacking
sequences so here Ponte E5 and now if
black had to retreat then of course the
white would be very happy even E6 is an
idea so Magnus goes forward Pawn to B4
as one usually does uh in every position
and here uh the position is a known one
night the E4 is a known move and also
Knights the A4 is a known move and those
are okay but Knight the B1 is a new move
so already as of move 10 we have a
completely new game but after this move
it it is kind of hard to defend the
White's position and the Magnus will now
demonstrate why Knight to D5 now putting
pressure on the on the bishop and also
just getting ready to start pushing
those pawns Bishop to G5 now preparing
if something like C5 then you can
capture here the the pawn is spinned so
knight seven to B6 uh and we have Rook
the E1 as a cross and skiing is still in
the center of the board it doesn't make
sense the uh prepare an attack against
him or even just force him to Castle
King's side or which he doesn't he goes
just Bishop to E6 he wants to attack
arjun's Queen side and now Pawn to F4
now it's interesting that uh White
already played the D4 E5 f for H4 but
it's very very hard to attack a Black's
setup when when executed uh in this way
even with the blacking still in the
center of the board the board you can't
just push something so here we have
Queen to D7 by Magnus now getting ready
to start pushing that pawn and also
Queen to A4 is is a move at some point
with Bishop to D3 uh in the Now Pawn to
A5 we have Queen to E2 here it's not
easy to find the move for white like I
said you really want to push some pawns
but there really aren't any good Pawn
pushes F5 is covered and also G4 is
covered so how are you breaking through
here the the fact of the matter is you
are not and here Arjun plays Queen to E2
and this is something that you should
remember for your own games uh when
you've Castle Queen side in structures
like these it's uh well it's sort of
maybe you you could have this like in uh
in the night or with opposite side
castles okay if c5c captures on D4 was
played something similar but if the
queen is a need to uh Magnus gets a
great idea he castles Queen side the
point is you can't really uh start C5 C5
Bishop B5 and uh okay you blunder your
queen so Magnus Castle's Queen side and
now we have Knight to F3 Arjun
continuous development King to B8 and
now Knight B to D2 We have Queen to A4
now putting pressure on the A2 pawn and
the white is without a good reply here
the problem is if King the B1 uh that's
why I said uh always be mindful of
placing your queen and E2 in such
positions just Knight the C3 check
that's the problem uh now you have to
capture and once you capture just Queen
A3 and you're getting checkmated Knight
A4 and queen to B2 will be checkmates
there's no good way to stop this however
you try it's just not possible you might
uh I mean even Knight here to guard this
just Bishop captures it there's no way
to survive so instead Arlington plays e
captures on D6 we have C capture Sun D6
and now Bishop captures and G6 hoping of
course for captures and then Queen
captures an E6 but Magnus just plays
Queen captors on A2 we have Pawn to F5
uh attacking the bishop here but just
Knights the A4 not worrying about that
going after the B2 Pawn so Knights the E
for freeing up the D2 Square for the
white king but just Queen captures on B2
we have King to D2 Knight a to C3 now
attacking the White Queen Queen D3 and
now Bishop D7 going for Bishop to B5 and
that's it there is no way to save the
White Queen uh Bishop captures on F7 is
played but just Bishop to B5 and that's
it Queen characters on B5 was played
Knight captures Bishop captures on D5
but now just Knight captures on D4 and
he was in this position on move 26 that
Arjun irrigation resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here I
want to try something or it's a very
hard to
find the movie you can actually play C2
is hanging let's say Knight characters
Queen captures with check you lose the
bishop so there's really not all that
much you can do you can defend with Rook
to C1 but just Rook to C8 you're gonna
pile up on that pawn and that's pretty
much it
uh so yeah nicely played by by Arjun but
uh it's hard to say if this was uh uh
you know if he messed up the preparation
as um like I said 94 and 90 for our are
the known moves that actually work in
this position for white uh or did Magnus
just uh not fall for any any trick in
the in the preparation uh whatever the
case uh very nicely yeah I played by
Magnus he took advantage of the of the
only opportunity basically Arjun gave
him and did not let go for the for the
rest of the game
uh so yeah uh thank you guys for
watching uh I would like to thank
Matthew Garner Luke longbone Joy Tyler
uh Laura York and Marcelo de Barros for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
this very nice tournament until it
finishes do you use hashtag suggestion
if you guys are interested in checking
out some games I already have some nice
suggestions for the uh
um versus Evancho game so stay tuned for
that as well uh but yeah pretty much it
hope you guys enjoyed it uh see you soon
and uh well have an excellent rest of
your day or or evening